When I first came to Georgia Tech, David Harel came and gave a talk.
And, as in the paper, in the talk, he talked about his digital watch.
And he presented a model of the digital watch.
He, he in fact had used that as a way of stressing his diagramming technique to
see if it was capable of representing the features of the, of the digital watch.
>From the paper, here's,
here's the example of the digital watch, from a high level view.
Notice that there are really two states here.
One is the dead state and one is the alive state,
separated by whether the battery is placed inside it or so on.
And then are five concurrently executing sub machines inside the alive state,
each of which has their own activities going, going on, and
there's even further nesting down in the lower right-hand concurrent machine.
The fact that state chargts support nesting means you can pull out any of
these sub-machines and consider them independently.
You can even provide details in the pulled out version that weren't visible in
the top level version.
Here's an example of the stop watch state.
It makes use of a history state.
You'll notice there it had it's own default state for
the, for the stopwatch itself in the zero step.
There's also a guarded transition using the in keyword that I mentioned before.
Here's a pullout on the displays state.
Notice that the state itself has a self transition over on
the left that indicates that there's a two minute timer.
What this is saying is if you were in one of the display states,
other than the default state, after two minutes it will,
it will flip back unless you were in the stopwatch state,
in which case it'll keep, keep you looking at the stopwatch.